[Music]
an out-of-place artifact is
any historical object that seems at a
glance to go against our understanding
of historical chronology
some artifacts appear too advanced for
the technology of the period in which
they were created
and seem almost like they've fallen out
of time the exciting mystery of these
artifacts has led to a range of wild
speculation
involving everything from aliens to time
travel
as much fun as it is to think someone
with a flux capacitor popped by and
accidentally left a
cell phone in ancient rome most of these
objects have reasonable explanations
but the real historical context behind
these out-of-place artifacts and the
ancient cultures which produce them can
be just as interesting as speculative
theories
so let's take a look at seven of the
most thought-provoking and uncover how
such astounding artifacts were created
the anti-ketheria mechanism is an
ancient greek object which has amazed
archaeologists historians and
classicists for decades
the artifact consists of various
incomplete bronze gear fragments which
once formed a kind of primitive machine
sometimes described as the world's first
analog computer
it was discovered in a shipwreck off the
coast of antikytheria island
most archaeologists believe greek
scientists constructed the mechanism
around 87 bc
the technological prowess on display
wouldn't be matched until over a
thousand years later
hence why it seems so out of place in
truth however the greeks around this
period were just that proficient with
complex gear work
with ancient literature describing in
detail the construction of similar
devices
but what did this early machine do based
on recreations
archaeologists think the mechanism was a
sort of astronomical clock able to
predict the position of the moon and
even eclipses decades in advance
likely for the purpose of astrology and
cultural festivals
other devices like astrolabes were also
used in later centuries to make similar
calculations but
none were at the same level as the
anti-ethereum mechanism for quite a
while
making the invention quite impressive
even if it isn't technically out of
place
up next we have the roman dodecahedron
small hollow objects made in the second
to fourth century ce
which looked quite bizarre at a glance
the 12-sided shapes are made of copper
and were spread all over the roman
empire with archaeologists discovering
over a hundred since the 18th century
funnily enough as far as we've been able
to uncover the ancient romans never
bothered to record what the purpose of
these dodecahedrons were
while the lack of explanation lends the
objects a certain mysterious power
truthfully it's more likely the romans
never recorded their
purpose because they were ordinary
enough that everybody already knew what
they were
archaeologists have put forth various
theories regarding their usage
including dice coin measuring and
knitting aids
but in this case the right answer is
probably the most mundane
trace amounts of wax have been found
inside some of the objects suggesting
the dodecahedrons were in fact used
as candle holders the iron pillar of
delhi is a metal structure now located
in delhi india
dating back to the 4th or 5th century ce
at 7.2 meters or roughly
24 feet high and over 3 tons or 6
000 pounds in weight it's an incredible
feat of engineering
any normal iron pillar would have
corroded away long ago
yet the pillar of delhi is famous for
its astonishing resistance to rust
despite being well over a thousand years
old indeed some have claimed the pillar
is completely rust-free
and therefore must be the result of
something beyond the realm of science
any actual photos of the pillar however
make it clear
this isn't the case there unmistakably
is rust on the pillar
even if it's in unbelievable condition
the real secret to the pillar's
longevity lies in the skill of 4th
century indian metallurgists who
constructed the iron pillar through a
complex process
involving rust resistant compounds it's
an inspiring feat of engineering
even if it's not something historians
somehow can't explain
the stone spheres of costa rica are a
collection of over 300 circular rocks
with mysterious origins
the objects are attributed to the
decrees culture an indigenous
civilization of costa rica which
flourished from 700 to 1530 ce
the spheres come in all sizes and have a
certain mystery to them
compounded by the fact their exact
significance remains shrouded in
uncertainty
most popular theories propose they were
placed in lines before the houses of
rulers but we really don't know
regardless of their exact meaning some
have suggested the sphere size
and impressive geometric roundness were
beyond the capabilities of the decreased
culture
frankly this isn't giving the decrees
enough credit the civilization was
highly advanced
producing other forms of impressive
sculptures like the metal effigy you see
currently whatever the cultural purpose
behind the spheres there is no reason to
suspect the dequeues society couldn't
produce them
the main penny is a norwegian silver
coin dating back to the viking age
the coin itself is ordinary enough but
what makes it an
out-of-place artifact is the fact it was
discovered in the state of maine in the
u.s
the coin's existence has been suggested
as evidence a group of vikings made it
all the way to the shores of modern day
north america during their travels when
the coin was first discovered in 1957
the idea of vikings ever crossed the
atlantic ocean was pretty new
but today it's a much more widely
accepted theory thanks to other forms of
evidence coming to light while the coin
itself does appear to be an actual
viking coin
there is still some debate regarding its
authenticity
as it might have been brought over by a
later traveler regardless this is the
one artifact on this list where the far
out explanation isn't actually that far
off and most historians agree is the
correct one
dogu are small statues from the jomon
period of japan with a distinctive
appearance to modern observers the
statues almost resemble a person wearing
a spacesuit
so did an alien or a time traveler
decked out in anachronistic gear
accidentally stumble around ancient
japan long enough to get statues made in
their likeness
maybe but it's far more likely the
resemblance to any modern clothing is
simply coincidental
indeed if these statues are considered
in context with other versions you can
see
most dogu look decidedly far off from
the distinctive spacesuit-like
appearance of the more famous figurines
the majority of dogu effigies from the
surrounding period actually place
emphasis on the wide hips more than
anything else with some lacking heads
altogether
the exaggerated hips and abdomens of
these statues has led historians to
theorize that they were in fact
associated with fertility instead of
spacemen
maybe not as exciting as time travel but
pretty interesting nonetheless
concluding our list we have the el
tannen antenna a mysterious object
photographed on the ocean floor in the
1960s
antarctic research ship the usnsl tannen
is the vessel which captured the strange
antenna-like artifact on camera
the ship was traveling west of cape horn
in south america when crew members
spotted the object at a strikingly deep
depth of over
3 900 meters or 12
800 feet below the ocean's surface in a
region close to total darkness
so what was this alien-looking object so
far below sea level
probably a type of sea sponge
chondrocladia concrens is a species of
carnivorous sponge with unusual
appendages which
vaguely resemble an antenna and is
almost certainly what the crew
photographed
a pretty wild organism even if it's not
quite as astounding as some deep-sea
radio dish
and that's the end of our analysis of
seven interesting out of place artifacts
and the explanations behind them
i hope you had fun and perhaps learn
something new along the way
if you did please consider subscribing
to curious archive
and leaving this video alike thank you
so much and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
you